We all have medical alternatives we trust, I mean nothing better than a pot
From the chicken soup is true hot? Well, it turned out that he might actually have an anti-inflammatory effect
As it prevents neutrophils, a type of white blood cells from moving, slowing down
The neutrophil movement prevents the cells from gathering in the area of ​​the lungs and thus
Eliminates congestion.
But perhaps you have also heard the words "feed the cold and hunger of the fever" - if it should
Only eat soup from time to time? This seems to be only half the truth. in both cases
You should actually eat nutritious food, which provides your body with energy to recover automatically
It increases something called interferon gamma - an essential component of the prevention of
Both viral and bacterial infections
So what about eating an apple? Because an apple a day keeps the doctor away, right? Well ... to some extent!
100 grams of apples contain the same antioxidant strength as 1500 grams of vitamin C
Which shows that it inhibits the growth of both liver tumors and cancerous colon
Its rich flavonoids are also associated with reduced risk of infection
Coronary heart disease. This can be associated with reduced visits to the doctor, and as a medicine
Preventing your general health, its effect on the common cold is still debatable
If and for taking too much vitamin C, whether in the form of lemon or other foods
Or pills? In a double-blind study, "this type of study or research means that both the researcher and the volunteer in the study do not know the dangerous area of ​​the experiment and study," it did not reduce the incidence
Common cold. However, the duration of the cold has been significantly reduced, this may be due to
Increase T cell growth of white blood cells that help in immune response
It also increases the secretion of interferon, which stimulates virus-infected cells
To produce their antiviral defenses
If you need an immediate cure for coughing or sleeping difficulties
From a respiratory infection, honey will help you! Known for its antibacterial activity, increases
From the release of cytokines that give signals to cells to repair themselves
And garlic? Not only vampires, but proved to reduce duration
The unit of cold and flu symptoms, by increasing the growth of gamma-delta-T cells
Natural killer cells, able to capture and remove extraneous objects
More effectively
Have you ever tried quenching? It is one of the most popular herbal supplements, and for good reason
In the "meta-analysis" on 14 studies, eugenics reduced chances of occurrence of the cold
By 58% and reduced the cold by about a day and a half today, it acts as an anti-inflammatory
It is similar to other alternatives that affect the production of cytokines in the body
And as long as you are in the same subject, I sensed some drink - with a little alcohol. Seriously some studies
I found that moderate amounts of alcohol can support your immunity. But before
To open a bottle of alcohol, take into account that their alcoholics are weaker
Immune system
If all other alternatives fail, water, rest and time will cure you
If any of the cold treatments is just an old and false myth? We will reveal the greatest myths of the disease that you are
You think it's correct in our new section on asapTHOUGHT, and we use scientific research and evidence
To expose them. Click on the screen or link in the Description box to see the section
By the way - our book - which answers more to your heated questions - will be released soon
So if you do not have your copy yet, go to asapscience.com/book and be
The first to get it
And subscribe to the channel for more weekly clips!